so wollte und jetzt sind meine haare
fertig geschnitten und ob ich genauso
wie dieser junge mann hier auf meinem
t-shirt jetzt aussehen das seht ihr in
321 wo sollte ich bin zurück mit einem
neuen video für euch und zwar mit einer
man muss wirklich sagen sehr dummen idee
jetzt orientierte gesehen meine freude
wird die haare schneiden ich war so
schlau vor dem lockdown kein
friseurtermin mehr zu machen
dementsprechend ist der wildwuchs jetzt
da und muss einmal getrennt werden
sondern dass man hatte ja komm ich würde
keinem menschen das eigentlich an
vertrauen aber auch ganz lustig ich habe
für möglich es muss jetzt passieren wird
und ich würde sagen wollte vor allem
eine freundin die keine frisörin es noch
nie jemanden gerade geschnitten hat ja
einen hund immer die habe vor meine ja
aber das wird nicht gestreikt heute
deswegen bin ich hier so dass wir direkt
loslegen können und wird sagen ja jetzt
auch mal das teil ist ein fang an leute
das ist das leben würden wir es für die
a gewesen ich habe mich auf jeden fall
ein gefährt dafür angeguckt wie das
funktionieren soll angeblich das kann
halt so kraft
ich glaube ich habe das wirklich nicht
gut gemeistert hat alle friseurinnen und
friseure jetzt schauen
sorry aber leute ganz wichtig bleibt bis
zum ende dran denn eine befreundete
frisörin von uns wird das ganze hier am
ende bewerten haben wir geschrieben wird
jetzt mal anschauen dann hätte meine
professionelle meinung noch im video
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommt man sagt ja und wie das kann so
nach hinten losgeht ich habe das
wirklich nicht gut
ein anderer gegner wie nichts ja das ist
das wirklich nicht eingeschritten wären
ja ok video wer ist ja okay machen
ich habe nicht die konsequenzen weil ich
wie lange es dauern wird das wieder raus
zu wachsen wir zwischen status
ich habe eigentlich ja wirklich angst
leute weil die sache ist eigentlich das
muss man im leben bei solchen sachen
immer bedenken was würde passieren wenn
es schiefgeht diesen gedanken habe ich
mir diesen fall einfach mal nicht
gemacht wenn sie irgendwie so dass jetzt
wie gesagt auf 10
ich machte gleich noch kürzer
ich will jetzt eigentlich auch sehen
ich freue mich auf den schnitt leute
dann weil dann sehe ich meine eigenen
haare geschoren werden
glück hat mir erzählt wie er sich
vorbereitet hat und zwar was ja einige
videos angeschaut was du gesagt ja so
ist sie auch bereit schlag mit unserem
folgen frisörin ungefähr machen sollte
aber nur ungefähr sollte ja ich habe mir
tag zwei tage vorher habe ich so schlimm
sieht es wirklich noch nicht aber gerade
in die kamera sieht auch sehr wild aus
jetzt gerade ich würde ehrlich ich würde
einfach so rocken jetzt mach maschine
auch im bilde was wird sein wie lange
sie meine haare so schon 67 cm oben
es dauerte dann ungefähr sechs monate
auf bis wieder nachwachsen
die gäste realisiert dass klartext moora
machst du die grenze fest bis wurden
hochwasser ist jetzt wurde ich hatte ein
bisschen weit von münchen
das ist ganz gut dazwischen
heute hab ich hatte mich gerade bei der
kammer auswahl das wurde prompt gefragt
leute wie findet ihr so weit wie sieht's
aus sieht scheiße aus und alle anderen
einstellung sogar perfekt
sieht so nachbarn hochhaus gehört ein
bisschen sagt heute ganz ehrlich so wir
haben jetzt heute den ersten januar am
januar sollte neu beraten
man weiß nicht weiter geht
da bleiben wir weiterhin locci alter cj
danken dass irgendwann muss etwas
passieren aber dann muss halt aus dem
häuschen ich weil ich gerade wie ich das
besser machen dann machen wir halt jetzt
gehört in dem moment waren wir schon mit
unserem latein am ende beziehungsweise
sie war mit ihrem latein am ende und wir
gedacht wird okay bevor wir jetzt
wirklich massiv schaden anrichten
berufen wir mal unsere freundin an die
frisörin ist und das ganze so aus
ob das vorhaben bis frei geschnitten und
habe hier schon so kurz gemacht aber wie
kriege ich das hier also das ja nachdem
ich dann hier erfahren habe dass da wohl
schon einiges im argen liegt haben wir
uns dann darüber versucht über facetime
rettungsaktion zu starten mit
professioneller beratung auch einmal ein
ende und meiner freundin allende und das
sei ungefähr so aus also meine freundin
wirklich ihr bestes gegeben hat es auch
ziemlich gut gemacht glaube ich von
laien so die drei stelle ich jetzt gar
nicht und dann natürlich brauchst ja
aber wir mussten eine andere lösung
finden und deswegen jetzt das folgende
ich habe kein gutes gefühl gutes gefühl
ich habe mir viele videos angeschaut und
ich habe mit der anderen jenny wenn ihr
die friseurin geredet und das wird auf
jeden fall funktioniert ich glaube nicht
jetzt nämlich an den punkt ich weiß
nicht ob es gerade gehört habt aber
unsere freundin jenny wie selbst
besucher ist wurde jetzt im ersten
arbeitsschritt zur rettung gerufen oder
zumindest zur übersicht dass wir dabei
ist und ja gerne wären wir auf die
retterin in der not war
macht ja nicht schon ein bild und
gemeinde sei wirklich immer ja das finde
ich aber ich kann nehmen muss
dann habe ich das gar nicht so schlimm
ich verkrafte ich glaube so viel
schlimmer ich finde es nicht so schlimm
das ist wirklich ist jetzt gerade ist
das 0 schlimm
die werte dann nicht weiter gästen aber
es ist jetzt nicht ich aber auch nicht
sie
für mich ist so logik gehabt ich halte
den betrieb mit dem holzschnitt aber
viele der canucks in der kamera vielen
dank an lara da hinten in der ecke
was aber schon oft hier reingepackt
deswegen siehst du halt das hier diese
ganz banal willkommen weil sie ja noch
wichtig ist halt auch dass du hier nicht
zu kurz ist weil sonst machst du denn
hier noch ein und männer die einander
her zurück und hatte hier so eine wurst
und hier quasi wände des hoch nimmt sie
ist ja schon hier ist jetzt kürzer hier
ist was länger hier ist wieder kürzer
und hier ist wieder kurz nach somit
quasi das sind gerade linie reinbringen
dass du da es zu lange ein bisschen
reingehen und jetzt hier ist wichtig
dass es mit der kopf von migranten
da hat euch genau den fehler gemacht ist
quasi sein
er ist nicht darüber sehr spät erst wenn
deswegen sage ich immer maximal so bis
hier gehen so gut linie weil dann kannst
du hier revidieren wie du willst dann
passiert nicht so viel wenn wir jetzt so
hoch ist weil das musste jetzt echt
ausbessern
du musst ja auch schneiden das ist echt
krass
das habe ich auch auf jeden fall noch
mal hat mir die reaktion gezeigt so ich
dachte auch so ok vietoris rheins hier
also irgendwie es wird nicht schön
aussehen aber irgendwie aktien kriegt
man es hin so die griffe und sonne
ich musste mich halt in meiner
ausbildung an den türrahmen stellen und
die ganzen so machen schere öffnet
carmen bewegen wie sie dumm kommt damit
du halt gerade erst mal bereits das
skript von morgens kam ich rein und
musste erstmal zeigen nicht geübt haben
das war sie rein und dann zu drücken zu
drücken zu drücken wenn du nämlich nur
halb so machst du ziehst du dich traust
du jetzt sind wir auf dauer so mancher
bei kindern die ich nicht mag aber die
gehören in jedes das geht mich das so
war
erst drücken und dann sehen ist mal
wieder typisch
es ist schwerer kämpfe alter sondern
professionell ist jetzt abgeschlossen
hat da kommt euch das hier mal an diese
seiten marshall wird
jetzt sieht es ganz gut aus sagt wir
sind hier oben jahre so nass wie jetzt
hier oben dran und ich probiere es also
dieses mal schneiden oder widerrufen
nicht nervös sein das kann ich so lange
du nicht reich das kind nicht nur jetzt
haben wir es ja jetzt kannst du genau
sie ist hier ist der kürzeste punkt dass
ich habe das irgendwie auf jeden fall
haben wir es dann in gemeinsame
anstrengungen nach vielem hin und her
vielen höhen und tiefen zu einem
endergebnis geschafft so und jetzt sind
meine haare fertig geschnitten und ob
ich genauso wie dieser junge mann hier
auf meinem tisch wird jetzt aussehe
das seht ihr in 321 diese seiten bruder
nicht auf zu viel da wurde noch einiges
geräte leute da wurde noch einiges gerät
wird man muss dazu sagen das ganze lief
er jetzt so denn hierzu angefangen und
bharat relativ schnell gesehen mit dem
professionellen blick dass das eine ganz
ganz falsche richtung geht deswegen
vielen dank
die notbremse gibt sogar leute wir haben
es getan bevor es eskaliert ich weiß
nicht ob sich gewünscht dass ich am ende
meiner klasse hier stehen weil ich habe
das gemacht aber so ist auf jeden fall
für mich besser abschnitt die seite
sieht
dieser sieht richtig gut aus und die
andere seite bisschen harte kante
abgekommen ja eure arbeit die waren sie
war auch schon ruiniert erklären
[Gelächter]
das alles alleine gemacht geh doch mal
noch okay leute alles alleine gemacht
man kann es auf jeden fall auch alleine
am besten noch selbst vom spiegels
überhaupt kein problem
in keinem fall könnt euch genau
spiegelverkehrt das gibt sich auf jeden
fall die einzige person die technik
geholfen das war ja nur wenige stehen ja
ich bin ja die habe ich möglicherweise
heißt der profi
das könnte natürlich sein dass ein paar
leute vielen dank fürs zuschauen so weit
ich weiß wo ich vorschlagen kann man
haben hin
ich bin schneller raus bin froh dass ich
nicht gestorben wenn ihr jetzt euch
gewünscht hätte dass ich gestorben
werkstatt in den kommentaren posten
das hat hier jede like heißt das
wünschen zu gestalten einen like ist
gleich einen todeswunsch